d'ici quelques heures les électeurs
s'attrouperont devant les bureaux de
vote le quart d'entre eux ont déjà voté
par anticipation un record merci les 4
millions 760 000 autres électeurs
devronter à partir de 9h30 lundi après
36 jours de campagne qu'en pensent les
électeurs
tous les promesses et tout seul c'était
comme du vide
à pleurer je l'ai trouvé drôle
alors c'est pas gentil ce que je suis en
train de dire
plusieurs électeurs reprochent le manque
de propositions crédibles à tel point
que cet homme n'ira pas voter lui qui a
pourtant l'habitude de le faire
1000 aux enchères on y va ce père n'a
pas été convaincu par les parties il y
avait très peu de propositions
intelligentes qui ont été faites
malheureusement
puis aussi un certain fraterniste parce
que l'issue est connu depuis le début de
la campagne au marché public de Rimouski
il y a un peu plus d'intérêt envers la
campagne un château fort pékiste
pourrait tomber je pense aussi que ça va
être serré en effet le même parti qui
rentre depuis quelques années ici à
Rimouski puis je pense que cette année
ça va peut-être changer j'ai trouvé que
c'est une campagne ça va être du nouveau
c'est tout du nouveau monde ça fait que
ça va ça va faire un changement de
l'ombre au tableau pour la journée des
élections les bureaux de vote de 11
circonscriptions manquent de personnel
principalement en montée régie
l'anaudière et l'île de Montréal même si
il y a le fil d'attente là à 20h les
gens qui seront enfilent à 20h pour
voter le directeur général des élections
veut rassurer la population peu importe
le manque de personnel les gens auront
accès lundi à leur bureau de vote dans
toutes les circonscriptions du Québec il
demande d'avoir en main son avis
d'inscription et sa pièce d'identité
pour faciliter l'une des étapes les plus
importantes de notre démocratie ici
Marie-José paquet como Radio-Canada
Montréal
[Musique]